hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the sexy brute owl nah
this game caught my eye because when you
see the word sexy and brute all together
in one sentence you kind of want to find
out what's going on so supposedly it's a
time warping trying time-traveling
murder solving something something
something something did that make any
sense no good great this game was on
sale on Steam and I love me a good Steam
sale so I bought it right up who's gonna
kill me the Marquis is an enigmatic
owner and creator of the sexy brutal
Casino mansion every year he throws an
extravagant rager his impeccably trained
staff catered to their every desire but
this year something is terribly terribly
wrong the guests aren't getting what
they want at all or you can find that
out for yourself Katie Oh boon after all
you have all the time in the world
laughs Katie oh foon it's me your
eminent loft Katie Oh Boone oh I'm dead
or I'm drunk am I drunk or dead for me
being drunk would be the equivalent of
being dead because I can't drink hello
oh hi time to move old man who you
calling old miss oily blood hair yeah
how do you like it knock off attack on
Titan watching we call it alright
whatever
oh don't you saunter over to me with
your bluff none of that excuse you
oh don't even get close to what did you
why did you light my face on fire never
take your mask off why kinda wanna it
was in flames
alright whatever fine it will give you a
chance just a chance you are not weak
thanks for the compliment mysterious
blood fire face lady now will help you
okay remember I didn't ask for that but
he he is so so strong you talking about
markiplier I think you're talking about
markiplier there I mean there's a big M
on that chair so all my floor oh it's
gonna take for our money peroxide you
know like a club soda for that one get
up okay oh good I've got a man to hide
my horrible face burns oh boy alright so
the premise is I gotta figure out how I
got dead I think open door get through
the door I'm trying there we go
gotta move and then open why do I wanna
look at that am I gonna see something
scandalous something say uh-uh
it must be huh oh is that what was wine
what are you doing it
calm down Reggie they won't look for you
here okay alright then
probably talked about Reggie thanks for
the exposition of saying your own name
for me okay go through that door listen
oh this game is mysterious
alrighty then ah goodbye follow him
through the door what if I don't want to
I mean I'm gonna do it anyway but sure
[Music]
okay there's a lot of spying going on
here clandestine activities what are you
doing in there man what are you doing in
that vault hi
those my goodies all those my goody
knitties wait where is it this is
garbage who locks garbage and it's safe
I don't know who looks at other people
saves a thief that's who you want me a
sick blood fire face lady on you Oh
Lucas what have you done I don't know
what have I done what have you done
I'm terribly sorry sir oh oh no you can
please you don't know what's going to
happen
ah now there I must correct you sir I
know exactly what's going to happen okay
thank you inform me because I don't okay
now I get it what will happen is that
I'm gonna shoot you that's silly in the
chest and then I'm then I have a bastard
of a dough hey that guy was complaining
about the steam - I didn't want that
stain neither where am I now why am I in
here hello this is cool by the way
he's cool hi he's coming he's coming
I don't know trying to well close the
door why is he alright five minute hello
hi
oh are you about to shoot someone
messily in the chest let's have a look
alright number two nice one you could
have just pulled it off gently but you
had to break it ha it is still loaded
let's see if this works let's see if I
can I guess there's always Plan B if it
doesn't yeah
bash him in the face oh boy well that's
no good
can I spy through that no I can't I
gotta open that one do beti any day now
okay where oh that one I got a spy can I
hit a sweet hard DAP from that sweet
hook I'm terribly sorry
it this is where the time looping comes
in ah now there I must correct you sir I
know exactly what's going to happen and
now I do too not as dramatic the second
time the music's nice Oh got it man
what happened is I'm gonna shoot you
messily in the chest and then have a
bastard of a time getting the stain oh
that would work Oh God high blood lady
become I'm not calm I'm totally calm who
are you who are you calm my name's calm
applier how are you you were not seen
he's not chasing you look back through
the door
[Music]
okay where the hell is seven clubs
he can bloody well come and help me with
the body I'm not lifting it on my own
yeah don't get any blood on my mask he
did not see you okay he will not chase
you no one in this mansion will this was
my gift when I touched your mask it will
protect you but only for a short time
the staff are murderers here the guests
are victims but they are all controlled
dominated by the masks they wear I have
one more gift for you okay
this pocket watch is importante cool
broken pocket watch
thanks for the piece of garbage blood
lady you're gonna lay my face on fire
again I took it from the man you saw
murdered if you can return it to
sixpence he will be able to unlock its
full potential first you will have to
save him I have to go he will find me if
I stay okay sure use the pocket watch to
restart the day from 12:00 p.m. the
pocket watch is partially smashed and
resets at 5:00 p.m. if you can find some
way or someone to repair it you will
gain more control over time that's a
handy feature it's not so broken now but
I'm looking it that way here we you see
current guess it and guess you are
trying to save okay okay alright I like
it I like it I like it
Saturday I like it whoa I'm in the
chapel apparently we got stuff to do the
Marquise invites you to tonight's show
so okay alright bye then okay so what
are these all about the chair is old the
flawlessly I was reading that as you
explore the sexy Brutale your map will
be built up from the rooms you have
discovered okay alright then the
movement of characters you have seen
will be added to the map you can adjust
the time shown on the map by
using the time scrubber okay
[ __ ] then oh I got a move time as fast
as Bible on the table nearby okay good
wide this is several books clay
Rockridge fire is roaring its intensity
causes your heart to race maybe because
I remembered out my face was on fire oh
sorry sorry sorry sorry about that
that was my goof all right so if I go
through this door and I get the gun
before that other dude is able to get
the gun yeah it's in the other room hang
on it's in the room just over here it's
in this room right here so if I grab the
gun or maybe I unloaded I unload that
gun then maybe then no reaction to the
pocketwatch hunting rifle loading
chambers open and may already have
bullets inside I'm too late
oh god it's horrible how do I that mask
was not happy about me well [ __ ] I was a
little too late that's a much better
idea let's do that wait but not yet I
see okay but I've got time right now to
be able to unload this rifle right
I can't I break it off of here oh come
on there's got to be a way
oh crap okay so that's already got that
so what do I do stuff al but still very
dead maybe I'm imagining that if he if I
unload the rifle he'll probably just try
to find another way about around it girl
pouring wine someone was burning my face
off who's burning my face hello
oh they can't see me that's right they
can't see me so I got Blanco a Blanca
toid really okay he's walking out of
that one okay my face is on fire oh he
took it god damn it okay I have to how
do i f one alright let's restart the day
because now I know what I need to do so
we got a loop-de-loop
I lose that but I know where that is so
if I put the blank cartridge in the gun
then maybe he won't be able to shoot him
right away and then and only then I'll
have to find another way to save him
because I'm pretty sure that's not how
it all goes give me that sweet tank oh
no that's right he'd dunk ah he dug
through there first and that's big was
that where or was it one more over was
it one more over yeah I was that one
okay so we dug through there so I just
gotta wait till he dunkaroos through
that thing there and then once he's done
Dunga wronging there's a blank that's
right over there okay
starting to get it starting to get it I
think I get it yeah
so I can I can accelerate
never go do that work yeah I must have
right timing sorry sorry it didn't work
uh-huh you know I don't like the fact
that you're robbing so maybe it it's not
racing you probate ha it's a big dog
all right fine man what's a bingo
garbage a blank bullet casing plate
where is it oh no it's garbage
oh okay and good on go okay he's gone
get it get it get it got it get it good
get it get that okay then I just got a
go replace the doodad er with the doodad
ER and I'm good I'm all kinds of said
now I don't know why I've been set upon
this task and I'm sure I'm glad that my
face lights on fire every time I'm near
somebody that awfully is convenient
there well it may be already inside but
I have uh there we go blank cartridge
slides and easily the blank will be the
next shot okay
got it perfect all right cool I'm
terribly sorry sir
kachunk what no you can't please you
don't know what's going to happen
ah what he does not know now what's
going to happen either
KaBlam Oh what the hell what what is
wrong with this blasted thing a blank
for that better be a second round in
here
otherwise it'll be plan B for you I'm
afraid
ah now ah [ __ ] well well boo
[Music]
[Applause]
golden duck tracking job okay is he dead
did you somehow belong come in to death
with a candlestick also that organ got
jazzy alright this feels very different
why am I wearing this massive still I
don't know are you hello welcome to the
real world sir how you doing
yes peculiar thing and I think they're
expanding D ah so much better
alrighty then hello
good lord laughs cardio boon oh I forgot
my own name hello I've lost cardio bone
where are we do you know
wait is that my pocket watch the
strangest feeling I've been looking all
over through this you've done quite a
number on it I don't want to give that
up that controls time oh you fixed it
are you gonna give it all thank you okay
there that should see you're right all
fixed okay thanks for not questioning
why I have it not you then I think I
should get back to the party
Oh you's a [ __ ] watch on any ticking
clock this will save your game and set
the clock to his starting point for each
day with watch prepare the full day is
now open to you hey hooray yeah whoo
someone's having a slide tipple on the
job
good show sleep it off the Batmen
oh the dead guy oh the dead guy okay all
right then little sixpence is saved
great good oh hi blood lady
oh my floor well you look a lot less
friendly from this angle take his mask I
don't know if I want to do that you will
need its power again I don't know if
need is the correct word here I theme do
been thrust into this position by you
alright fine is this one I will light my
fire on face my face on fire my face
fire sure that feels good
alright clock mastery with sixpence mask
you can create a bond with clocks around
the house I can speak to the emotional
like heart of every clock I know I can
empathize with every clock in the entire
house use any act of clock in the
mansion to jump to 4:00 p.m. or 8:00
p.m.
you saved Reginald life he was the
personal clock maker to the owner of the
mansion the Marquis well he was more
than that but the mourn the important
things that the clock in the mansions
are tuned to him 9 now that you haven't
mask his power they will respond to you
you have to go quickly even now the
mansion is straining to undo what you've
done but you can fight back save it in
one life at a time this day will start
again I braved its expenses power will
free you from these rooms if you are
lost find me in the casino I will look
for you by the clock again ok I get it
by the clock there's so many more guests
who here who need your help ok why can't
you help them blood lady never mind then
I'm just gonna go back and dive don't
mind me cool great Saturday again got
that Saturday Night Fever boogie woogie
woogie night long oh hi I thought I
clobbered you there's that different are
you two of diamonds ok maybe that is you
you know it stays like this I wish I
were less competent and maybe I wouldn't
get into the tricky jobs
well hey welcome to the sexy portal okay
alright then oh man
it's safe yeah cool well anyway that is
the sexy brute owl
I don't know if I'm gonna play a full
round of this one it seems like it's
gonna be a bit of a longer game but it's
an interesting concept I like it a lot I
might do a couple more episodes just
because I'm curious as to what's gonna
happen next but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think down the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
you